the company that former president Donald
Trump has run for decades has been
convicted of breaking the law a jury
found that the Trump organization is
guilty on all 17 counts including
conspiracy and tax fraud after a
dramatic trial in New York Trump himself
was not charged and does deny wrongdoing
but prosecutors alleged she signed off
on years of criminal activity including
a variety of perks provided off the
books Robert Costa is in Washington with
more on this Bob good morning this is
not a civil case it was Criminal
that's right Tony good morning for
former president Trump this guilty
verdict is more than a legal blow for a
company that has long defined him and
his family it's also the latest
potential challenge to his political
standing just weeks after he launched
his 2024 bid for the White House
the Manhattan jury found the Trump
organization guilty on all 17 counts
following a trial where prosecutors
describe the company's culture as one of
Fraud and deception that culture
prosecutors found included off the books
non-tax perks for executives from least
luxury cars to private school tuition
the star witness longtime Trump
organization CFO Alan weiselberg he pled
guilty to tax evasion in exchange for a
five-month sentence and his testimony
well Trump himself was not indicted and
denies any knowledge of the scheme the
probe of his company which he has
boasted about for years did raise new
questions about his conduct with
prosecutors arguing that he knowingly
participated in the scheme the jury
verdict can be taken as a indication
that they thought he did know so that
has a lot of implications for or going
forward including by this very office
that is now considering new criminal
charges against him the maximum penalty
is 1.62 million which means the Trump
org does not face an existential threat
but the verdict could cast a shadow over
its reputation today's ruling is very
damaging to the Trump brand and now his
company that has been his sort of alter
ego in the business World stands
convicted of a 15-year scheme to defraud
will certainly do you appealing of
course a spokesman for the Trump
organization called The Verdict
Preposterous and defended its business
practices it is just the latest turn in
numerous Trump investigations in soon
the January 6 committee will issue a
sweeping report on Tuesday the committee
chairman told reporters the panel
expects to make criminal referrals other
members reiterated more would become
coming soon Donald Trump and others
committed criminal offenses in their
effort to prevent the peaceful transfer
of power we are discussing and I think
we're closing in our final decision
about whether to make referrals and
exactly what those referrals will be
this is just the latest turn in Trump's
2024 presidential campaign which he
announced last month and has already
been marked by controversy and while
most potential Rivals remain wary of
taking him on directly some are now
urging the party to move on generally
speaking from the past Tony that is true
Bob thank you very much